Hi, welcome to
Jupiter, the MIT CSA IL
weather information system,
featuring WSI Corporation's
Intellicast weather forecasts.
This call is being recorded
for system development.
You may hang up or ask
for help at any time.
How can I help you?
What's the weather forecast
for Boston tomorrow?
In Boston, Thursday, partly
cloudy skies, high 76.
Thursday night, partly cloudy
skies in the evening becoming
cloudy skies overnight.
Lows 59.
What other information
can I give you?
Is it going to rain
over the weekend?
In Boston, Saturday, slight
chance of a thunderstorm.
Sunday, isolated thunderstorms.
What other information
can I give you?
What's the weather
like in Taipei tonight?
In Taipei tonight, overcast
with rain showers at times.
Low 73.
50% chance of rain.
What other information
can I give you?